how we have found a member of the ftth
Council Europe 11 years and today you've
been awarded acknowledged for that
achievement how does it feel I have to
say it really feels great and it was a
very emotional moment for me when it was
there on stage and I got to disavow it
for the 11 years of pushing forward 50
to the home in Europe throughout the
ftth counts in Europe it was 11 great
years and I really enjoyed it doing all
this work in the last 11 years and today
being awarded that was really let's say
the big the big final thing in my role
in the ftth council now all that time
ago people must have still doubted
whether fiber-to-the-home could really
happen what for you have been some of
the significant landmark moment in those
11 years when I think back to 2,000 for
it was true when I was it the first
conferences we very very small
organization 25 members and I was
talking about 50 to the home a lot of
people were saying no no way this is far
away in the future and we were seeing a
bit of the de Crecy guys the technology
guys and in the last 11 years if you see
now how this changed it is a great
progress and never some i would say
milestones that we had during this time
the first one was when we reached around
80 members because that was the moment
where we could say we hire some stuff
and we can really do a much bigger work
and then of course when we reach 200
members around 2010 this was the moment
where we really got a strong voice in
Europe and just afterwards there was
this famous digital agenda for europe
and i'm still proud that at the end the
digital chain that not only has the
certain megabit but also the hundred
megabit in his text and this was one of
the big achievements reason FTTH council
did over the time other achievements
were when we did give me five a day
which we introduced a few years ago and
which is now growing and remembering
more and more end customers that fiber
is an important infrastructure and
finally of course if you look around
here the big f th conference that we
build up in the last year's yes I mean
that's gone from being a very nice event
in to what I may say is now
like shape avenging Europe hasn't it
indeed it is a flagship event and it's
even the largest FTTH event in the world
so there is nobody nowhere else in the
world the conference that is larger than
that one focusing on a 500 home
infrastructure I was just told when I
came in here that the 3,000 delegates
were already exceeded now so it's really
one of the big events and again it was
one thing that we started in 2004 with a
small conference 250 people coming
together and then it was growing up over
the years at 1,000 then we reached 2000
very said well that's the absolute
threshold and now we are at 3,000 since
several years which seems at the moment
to be the maximum size but my feeling is
due to the fact that the ftth topic is
growing in Europe we will have even a
growth of this conference in the next
year's but of course this is something i
will see you some visitor at them
exactly now I'm just going to come on to
that in the fact that you're here is
that very much a VIP visitor but no
longer officially a member of the
Council individually tell us about your
new role in Austria it sounds very
exciting it is very exciting so after 11
years of working with the council
talking to pull it up policymakers
decision-makers and telling them by five
of the home is important I got last year
the big chance to build such a fiber to
the home network there is a company in
the state of Lower Austria in Austria
that will build 50 to the home and
absolutely only 50 to the home by the
next ten years to five hundred thousand
households so this is by far the largest
travel home project in Austria and I got
the chance as a CEO to guide this
rollout and to say all the things that
we prepared in the last 11 years Europe
provide I can prove now in front of my
house because I'm living in this region
I'm thirsty well they certainly got the
right man for the job thank you very
much for joining and congratulations
again on the award sexual prime